and welcome back everybody so we're
keeping you updated on the murder case
involving four University of Idaho
students there is a conflicting report
that is surfaced ahead of Brian
coburger's status hearing on Thursday so
Shannon gray who's the family attorney
for victim Kaylee Gonzalez he says that
no one knew coburger before the murders
but according to last week's probable
cause affidavit released by Moscow
officials coburger was in the area of
the victim's home at least a dozen times
before the attack that information which
was gathered gathered through cell phone
data also puts co-burger at the crime
scene hours after the attack the 28 year
old was attending Washington State
University at the time less than 10
miles from the Idaho crime scene gray
has previously said that the victims
gave no indication that they were being
stalked but that if any of the families
find any information connecting the
victims to coburger it will be turned
over to police a Time the suspect could
have visited the home was during one of
their off-campus parties you see the
home had a reputation as being a party
house in fact police bonded to at least
two noise complaints just a few months
before the murders body cam footage
captures officers speaking with three of
the victims Kaylee gonsalves Madison
Logan and Zana kernodle during two
separate incidents
is this your place yeah perfect snow
over here and I assume noise noise yeah
yeah big speaker right there yeah
nothing against having a party once
Neighbors start calling in then we have
an issue fair so usually at least for me
I'll give you a verbal warning okay uh
once I have neighbors calling in your
music's too loud you're disturbing the
piece yeah nothing against having
parties nothing against having people
over who are over age to drink but again
once we start disturbing the neighbors
then we've got an issue if this is your
place so I'm gonna hold you responsible
because it is your place you're also
responsible for everybody here yeah so
I'm gonna grab your info yeah and if I
do have to come back here uh a 300 some
dollar tickets come in your way okay and
only gets more expensive from there it's
not fair yeah that's fair absolutely all
right Madison so here's the deal okay
they've already said that no one here
lives uh like none of the the occupants
that live at this address are here right
now so now you have a house full of
random people
um you need to let them know that the
noise needs to needs to come down okay
we just received a noise complaint we
want that music turned down
um and we don't want to come back again
tonight if we have to come back again
tonight then there's even more problems
okay I see both sides I'm just
frustrated I'm also sorry once again no
I've never had to deal with this out
there and we don't want to start now I
don't ever remember having to come here
so I understand you guys are having to
get together but people have a way of
taking the invitation and using it as an
excuse to get out of control and be loud
exactly okay I'm so sorry it's okay I
just I just hope for your sake that your
friends don't put you in a position
where you get the citation and you have
to go to court to defend yourself from
your friend's Behavior makes sense
just so chilling scene when they're only
a few months before this so I'll bring
back in Brian and Terry on this so Terry
the affidavit places co-burger near the
house numerous times before the murder
but surviving roommates didn't know him
so if you were the prosecution how do
you explain that well a couple things
here first of all if he's near the house
but outside the house what the
prosecution is going to have to argue is
he was casing the house he was going
around trying to figure out what are the
entrances what are the exits how can I
get in so that's one possible
explanation for his being there and the
victims not knowing him because he never
entered the house but as we saw in those
clips there were multiple parties at the
house apparently and there were noise
complaints so it could very well be that
he was inside the house because those
cell towers put him in that area if he's
in the house and there are lots of
strangers then perhaps we just don't
know whether or not any of the victims
literally ran into him there could have
been a hundred people in there and they
could be all people from the school and
they don't know everyone who is in that
school so I think they would have to
basically say they didn't run into him
and the prosecution is going to have to
prove that that was what exactly
happened he might have been in the house
but the victims didn't see him I you
know if he was in there he just would
stand out he's older he looks different
so Brian let's go back to that hearing
that's on Thursday what should we expect
from that yeah going from arrest to an
actual trial can sometimes be a long
tedious process full of procedural steps
I'm expecting in this status update the
judge is going to want to get the ball
rolling because don't forget coburger
has a right to a speedy trial I'm
expecting maybe a plea of not guilty and
moving forward an expectation of an
indictment through a grand jury and then
Discovery that's going to be handed back
and forth between the two parties all
right we'll wait and see when we come
back social media addiction anyone with
kids knows it is a real thing and it can
cause a lot of problems well now
plaintiffs are lumping their grievances
together to go after big attack
[Music]
a new lawsuit is consolidating more than
100 cases involving huge social media
platforms that we all know Facebook
Instagram YouTube Snapchat Tick Tock
family say these apps are really bad for
children lawyers involved with the case
are comparing the legal filing to the
fight against tobacco and opioids
they're going up against Tech Giants big
Tech Giants to try to find liability
social media users and those suing on
their behalf say that sites like
Instagram are designed to be addictive
while exposing kids and teens to
self-harm and eating disorders and other
mental health problems in fact just last
week Seattle Public Schools also filed
suit against big so big Tech social
media companies saying their misconduct
has been a quote substantial factor in
causing a youth Mental Health crisis in
2021 a Facebook whistleblower testified
that Facebook knew its platform was
harmful to certain groups like teens but
just targeted them anyway another app
that's making headlines or ones that
companies use to track their employees
locations a man in Florida says that he
called out sick from his job at a tow
company and then went and put out an
application and a competitor when his
employer saw that his name popped up on
the tracking tracking software they
fired him Gary Leedy says he knew the
app called Toe book was always tracking
his location lady says it was a company
requirement that he have a Duke be on
his personal phone then he'd not make
any changes to the settings now the
company disputes that but Leedy says he
had been excused from work for the sick
day and was there for him personal time
so it shouldn't have mattered where he
was in the tracking software I'll bring
him Brian and Terry Bryan employer
firing you based on tracking your
whereabouts that seems like a pretty
serious issue he has to have some sort
of case yeah so the headline seems big
but in this case I would say don't let
the headline confuse the actual facts of
the case the case itself he's lying
saying that he's sick and he's going to
a competitor to try to pick up an
application to handle the job now he and
all employees know they can turn off
this app that doesn't track them but he
left it on and the company isn't going
to a computer and searching them they're
searching all of their employees to make
sure that they're making deliveries at
time and they are passively watching and
see him going to a competitor he doesn't
have a case but the issue of employers
having more information and breaching
our privacy just by virtue of working
there happens I have a cell phone my
company can track me because I have my
emails going to here they have to have
access to my personal phone and also my
health this is the first time we've ever
had to tell our employers about our
health and vaccination status so there
is a fear of losings in privacy but in
this case I don't think it's valid Brian
you may not know this I am tracking you
I know about where you are at all times
don't worry about it we're talking about
it off there Terry I want to go back to
the other lawsuit so you mentioned to me
that the plaintiffs that are filing
actions against these social media
companies that they may face an uphill
battle what did you mean by that well
this is a product liability case in fact
there are multiple cases across the
country and they've been Consolidated in
this multi-district litigation but it's
stretching what product liability really
means usually it's a defective product
and there's going to be injury that's
caused from that defective product it
can either be negligence or strict
liability or even a warranty for that
matter but here the defective product is
because it was marketed to these
individuals particularly teens and is
that really defective and it's causing
addictive behavior but is that really
the fault of the company who
manufactured these social platforms so I
think it's stretching it and I think
it's going to be very difficult to prove
that because you're addicted to it
you've been injured by it by the way
shout out to our producers for that
amazing b-roll I mean that is social
media kids just doing whatever they do
on their phones Brian Terry thanks
everybody thanks everybody for watching
the daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America